melons yeah melons
you know what am I do to make her laugh
because she's a real Tyrant she rolls
with an iron fist oh oh my God oh my God
[Music]
yeah no I actually have an actual
telephone that works that's a banana a
banana phone yeah when it rings does it
go ring ring ring banana phone no it
goes like this
like when you eat a banana you know what
it sounds like do you know what it
sounds like it really does you're such a
legend I'm so excited everyone says this
to you but I'm so excited to meet you it
is so crazy and I'm not usually doing
this but I Gotta Give the compliment
right back to you Alex I think that you
are the cat's pajamas oh that's so nice
I saw your show and now it's going to
Broadway hear your laugh in the crowd
might actually pull Focus but it would
be so amazing to have you there you want
to hear my laugh yes please huh
ha ha it sounds like someone being hit
with a bowling pin on his leg Yeah but
it you know like you gotta laugh like
that well that's my laugh that's not
your laugh there's nothing I can do
about it really you don't have a sort of
like but everyone has different Labs
right that's your do you have a sort of
like subtle chuckle some people have
like there are different laughs for
different things I'll do like a laugh
scale with you you know how like people
they do the song scales we could do like
a laugh scale okay so you have a
neighbor who tells you a bad thing that
has happened to someone that you mildly
dislike so it's like uh something bad
happened to someone you dislike
all right now you're witnessing that bad
thing happening to someone you just like
finally
okay you're watching the Best comedian
in the world
Gallagher too you know I stripped him
back in the day Gallagher too wait
there's a two yeah there's a second
Gallagher I hope it was the original
Gallagher I don't wear bras I never have
no that's one that's part of your brand
well you know have you ever worn a bra
I mean yes
well you know the word on the street is
that you are like the new Seinfeld which
you know not a bad comparison they're
not saying the new Gallagher you know I
thought it was one of the best things
I've ever seen in my entire 82 years
here on this planet if you had to
compare it to something previously given
all your life experiences there are they
first of all thank you so much I think
of myself more as a new George Costanza
but you know that's uh do you like to
have a sandwich while because that's my
favorite thing that George put out into
the world like it's okay I thought you
don't you told Chris Bradley that's what
Marlon Brando did well I said where did
you think Costanza got it it's because
when Marlon and I used to hit the sack
back in the day he couldn't wait long
there was no agility we just went down
you know we sort of plumped on the sack
you know you know I met maybe I
shouldn't say this in any recorded
medium but I met a lady once who was who
is around your age she said that she
used to
um get with Frank Sinatra and I said
what was Frank Sinatra like because I
had to know then she said as a lover and
I said yes and she went strictly
[Laughter]
you know some men I gotta say don't
think that they have to try I've got all
this going on guess what I don't have to
make an effort how do you feel how do I
feel do you feel like you have to make
an effort yes I feel like I have to I
feel like I have to work very hard
there's lots of others look I have
sympathy for Brando there's snacks
there's good lighting there's good music
the playlist is curated by Questlove
like the whole thing like everyone like
I there's lots of effort that goes in
that goes into it I would call that love
making that's the definition of
lovemaking when you put a lot of love
into it what's the alternative you can't
say it Sinatra apparently and we've all
had a few of those you know
let me give you a Yelp review zero
unbelievable that's why they don't think
they have to work hard your show is
going to Broadway yes how do you feel
about that excited super nervous do you
have any advice for me I mean given
you're such a comedy Legend I personally
don't think that you should change a
thing that you should do a thing that
you should worry about a thing because
if your material got you all the way to
the world's largest stage Broadway then
you know you must be doing something
right and the one question that I came
out of there with you know because I
actually like shed a tear I was shocked
yeah you were very emotional afterwards
it was really it was really nice but I
was these eyes don't water you know
they're real dry I go to the optometrist
and they're like Listen to It's it's
like cobwebs and dust in there you know
use a drunk your optometrist calls you
to itself yeah because he's my age you
know okay golden the way you talk about
you know your religion and how people
have things that they don't like about
people there are plenty things I don't
like about people but I it breaks my
heart you know when people take it to
another level and your show is so full
of humanity it transcends and it makes
me remember well I'm missing it's very
it's very I didn't expect such
sentimentality from you neither did I
kid neither did I I I just it's time for
the spit take no I know I've seen okay
so what's a pirate's favorite letter of
the alphabet
is that an R
you'd think it'd be arm it is to see
that he loves
that's the one that made you laugh and
so stupid all I want to know is can I do
a weekend at Banana mores that's what
Marlon Brando ass dude no sound joking
no he would go Thursday to Sunday as
long as there were enough sandwiches and
Deli Cuts you know around kid I'll book
you any day and I just don't say that to
people you bring something out of me you
soften me you make me go wet I don't
like it but I I gotta go with it because
it's my truth I love that I like you a
lot I like you too you want to touch me
no no absolutely not I'm sorry I mean
oh
that's what it feels like oh my God
remember no Brock head no bra
[Music]